Hallo, Stefan.
Haben wir uns wieder zum Salon gefunden, hier in der Kälte. Seit gestern ist es hier kalt. Auch im virtuellen Salon.
Gestern. Ich habe dem aber entgegen gefiebert heute um 10 Uhr Donnerstag, 10 Uhr mit dir hier zu sitzen und noch immer nicht zu wissen, wer jetzt der nächste Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika wird und Stefan, ich muss da jetzt natürlich ein bisschen nachbohren, denn du hattest uns da ja eigentlich einen ganz klaren Sieger versprochen. Also du hast ja eigentlich schon nicht mehr gewollt, dass wir überhaupt noch groß diskutieren.
Richtig.
Sondern du sagtest, beiden ist durch, brauchen wir nicht mehr drüber sprechen.
Ja, es ist tatsächlich noch ein bisschen, also gestern war nicht nur der erste Gefrosttag hier in Frankfurt, sondern es ist auch wirklich kalt geworden gestern, als zürgen plötzlich die Dementoren über den Dächern Frankfurts hinweg und hätten uns allen kurz die Lust geraubt. Nein, das betrifft nur mich soweit. Mein restliches Umfeld hat das locker weggesteckt, glaube ich. Mich hat es aber schon ein bisschen mitgenommen, ehrlich gesagt. Und naja, wir werden im Salon gleich die Angrynomics besprechen. Das ist ein Buch, das handelt von Gefühlen. Wut als politischer Akteur, sag uns mal so.
Und wie das mit der Wirtschaft zusammenhängt, sehr interessant.
Genau. Und ich hab mich gestern das Buch natürlich schon im Hinterkopf und so für unser Gespräch heute schon so gefragt, liegen die Autoren noch richtiger als sie eigentlich glauben? Haben sie sich beim Thema Wut einfach nur eine Emotion rausgesucht? Und dann müssten wir eigentlich über so viele Emotionen und Emotionsübertragung und alles Mögliche, also du bist ja der Psychoanalysen-Experte, ich hab das alles nie gelesen von Freud, aber ich glaube, es fand eine große Übertragung statt von amerikanischen wütenden Wählern zu europäischen ängstlichen Bürgern plötzlich. Die wütenden amerikanischen Wähler haben uns Europäer gestern sehr ängstlich gemacht, war mein Gefühl. Und ich hab's an mir gespürt. Wie hast du den Wahltag mitgemacht?
Ich habe ihnen eigentlich mit Lektüre zugebracht und hab immer nur zwischendurch einmal geschaut, ob es ein neues Ergebnis gibt, hab aber mich ziemlich ausgeklinkt, habe fast nichts verfolgt im Fernsehen, auch kein CNN oder so. Also die wenigen Ausschnitte, die man bei Twitter mal bekommen hat, die hab ich vielleicht hin und wieder auch angeklickt. Ich glaube, das letzte, was ich wirklich bewusst so geschaut habe, waren diese letzten zwei Minuten, die Trump veröffentlicht hatte, am Wahltag. Da gab's nochmal diesen Zusammenschnitt von seinen Auftritten und aber keine Botschaft mehr, sondern nur noch YMCA. Und das fand ich nochmal so ganz charakteristisch eigentlich für diese Wahl oder für diesen Präsidenten auch, dass am Ende eigentlich die Show nochmal steht und dass man nochmal versucht, mit dieser Show das hinzubekommen. Ich war etwas überrascht dann doch, nachdem du mir das ja so plausibel gemacht hast, dass Biden auf jeden Fall gewinnen wird, dass es dann doch sehr knapp ist. Und ich habe mich gefragt, wie sinnvoll ist es überhaupt noch, sich mit Demoskopie zu beschäftigen? Oder muss man sagen, das ist ja auch ein Thema von Angrynomics, geht es dann am Ende darum, dass Tribalismen angesprochen werden, also kleine Identitäten, und die sind am Ende Wahlentscheidung. Die werden aber von der Demoskopie nicht richtig erfasst. Das war die Frage, die ich mir gestern gestellt habe, weil ich ja auch das Buch am Lesen war.
Genau, dann switchen wir gleich in den Salon. Angrynomics ist das Buch, das uns nochmal erklärt, wie man in einer Welt, in der offenbar Inhalte nichts mehr zählen und die bisherige Demoskopie versagt, trotzdem Erklärungen möglich sind. Es trotzdem noch Erklärungen gibt und diese haltlose Welt nochmal in eine Heuristik reinholt, bei der man auch dann noch einen klaren Kopf bewahren kann, wenn plötzlich aus dem Nichts 10 Millionen Wähler auftauchen, die einfach nur wütend sind und mit sonst niemandem reden.
Ist das das Silent Majority Stands With Trump? Also sind das die, die, wie du sagst, nicht ans Telefon gehen? Die sagen, mach ich nicht.
Unerreichbare Menschen.
Ja.
Aber dann sind sie da, wenn sie gerufen werden, wenn sie von ihrem, wenn sie, wenn sie der richtige Rufe eilt, dann sind sie plötzlich da. Also ganz hoch unter der Lektüre gleich. Dann diese uns noch, was du sonst noch in petto hast.
Es wird um Indien gehen und die Wanderarbeiter in Indien. Es geht um einen interessanten Roman von der argentinischen Schriftstellerin Samantha Schweblin. Dort werden Menschen zu kuscheltieren. Und dann blicken wir noch auf die Podcast Szene. Wir blicken auch noch nach Afrika. Dort steht vielleicht eine Währungsreform an. Und was wird diese bedeuten? Ja, das sind so meine Themen. Und ein großartiger Text. Also es wird sehr digital und sehr finanzpolitisch. Zu Huawei von Yevgeny Morozov. Ganz, ganz großartig.
Von ihm lange nichts mehr gelesen. Ja, ich habe Reed Hastings Netflix Chef. Der hat sein Unternehmen Bullshit-Job freigemacht. Das ist jedenfalls sein selbstgestellter Auftrag. Das werden wir mal anhand seiner Selbstbeschreibung kritisch überprüfen. Yoga vorm Schlafengehen verbessert das Leben. Und es macht Sinn, sich ganz langweilige Newsletter zu schreiben. Newsletter, die mit Absicht langweilig sind. So langweilig, dass man schon in die Betreffzeiten schreibt. Das ist langweilig, was ich schreibe. Und es hat trotzdem so viel überraschenden Sinn. Das werde ich gleich aufklären und stellt sich raus. Die Klimakrise ist viel billiger als die Corona-Krise. Ich würde sagen, dann gehen wir mal rein. Bis gleich. Alle, die gebucht haben, je nachdem, entweder eins vorher oder eins nachher im Podcatcher taucht der Feed-Salon auf. Allen anderen, die jetzt überlegen, in den Salon zu kommen, sage ich noch mal ausdrücklich, ich habe es auch noch mal auf die Seite geschrieben, wenn man gebucht hat auf die Bestätigungsseite, weil die Frage häufiger kommt. Der Salon ist ein ganz normaler Podcast. Man bekommt den Feed aber nur, wenn man dafür bezahlt. Also man findet ihn nicht über die Suche im iTunes Store oder sonst irgendwo bei Podcasts, sondern man muss ihn dann manuell eintragen. Das macht man genau einmal und danach ist er als ganz normaler Feed im eigenen Podcatcher drin. Man muss es also nicht auf der Seite hören, man ist nicht an den Browser gefesselt, sondern man kann seinen üblichen Podcast Freuden nachgehen, die Küche aufräumen, den Garten machen, spazieren gehen, was auch immer einschlafen. Man kann das abseits des Computers machen, denn es ist ein, es ist und bleibt ein normaler Podcast. Er kostet nur ein bisschen Geld.